and I guess let's start with what they
showed off first which was the call of
duty zombies spin-off the lion what is
this mike so that's the sony exclusive
like kind of story driven zombie stuff i
guess i mean all the zombies kind of
have their own stories but the one
killing for all I'm zombie has its own
this is filled their people well this is
all I feel well it's the continuation
like this is a zombie story we've gotten
since the first game yeah and continuing
those characters and going on as opposed
to the the other standalone war story
which we've seen more trailers of and
have some more like some of the bigger
actors yes the shadows of evil is the
one that's like 1930s kind of its ron
perlman is voicing one who looks like a
jeff goldblum great player I played that
pretty extensively and it's it's weird
to hear Jeff Goldblum just talking about
zombies he's always got his you know
dulcet tones I he's kind of very mod
yeah he's odd but yeah he's in a we
raise this is kind of what like a lot of
people have been talking about for a
while which is like when it is on bees
going to take over like it's become such
a popular part of the main franchise and
it do you think this is like a step in
that direction Justin I you know I don't
know that it's necessarily taking over
like I think it's always been a big part
of of what call of duty is and this is
just kind of feeding into that like you
want that the main call of duty
experience and that's you have to call
the game call of duty but you also want
that something like this amies are just
that fun addition and I think it's more
saying this is something you're always
gonna get don't worry we're not going to
take this away but and it's not just a
like a small ad on like this is its own
separate thing do you could it be its
own game though like I almost feel like
it could like this could be the fourth
set of Call of Duty other fit with a
fifth one at this point maybe the
franchise maybe this is then testing the
waters because even saying that okay
we're going to make this sort of like
you know expansion or whatever you want
to call us and specifically about the
zombies is sort of like showing that
they're there knee deep in the dead as a
work yeah they're taking it seriously by
the looks of it so is this an expansion
pack is this standalone is this what the
hell is this well so and so it's kind of
one of those weird in-between things it
is fine it what is an expansion what is
dlc it is downloadable content it
doesn't fit directly into the main game
i mean you still have black ops dudes
its own standalone experience but you
have to
in black ops 3 to play this yeah it's
not like this is not a separate game
that you're going to be able to buy and
purchase I think those right now it's a
pre-order bonus when you get it through
gamestop or certain retailers are
offering this is here's your owner bonus
I'm sure there's going to be a way to
get it down the line outside of
pre-ordering yeah like they always been
hopefully not too expensive though down
the line because it's a little bit
strange if they're gonna release this
big thing that's substantial on its own
and say but you also have to buy this
full game to get it when it's totally
detached from it I'm almost weird that
they're announcing it now before the
game has come out it seems like a
PlayStation experience kind of
announcements but maybe the Parisians
really love zombies I don't like you
excited about playing this uh yeah that
specifically I mean I have a few friends
that get the tray arcs called duties
specifically for zombies don't touch
like barely touch multiplayer and can't
let alone campaign but it's always fun
to jump online and kind of there's so
many secrets throughout these and it's
fun to it's one of those things you
really have to master because these get
hard you play zombies in the other games
and it you get to around 7 and you're
dying I mean that was the thing about
the gameplay they were showing today
there were four times I saw I look like
they're just about to die but it still
looked cool but uh yeah I'm always
excited for the zombies more so than the
other modes in turn tioning secrets like
people are still finding secrets from
some of the earlier Union wasn't yeah
there was that secret recently where
somebody found like if you put the gnome
in this specific spot and then I can't
remember exactly what it was do you know
what I'm talking about I know what
you're talking about I don't know
specifically what it was but yeah it's
crazy that that was from what black ops
oh I think black ops 1 yeah black ops 2
but uh cuz yeah but it's crazy that
there's so many hidden things I mean it
took me a few weeks to start to master
even like der riese the third one that
ever came out for world at war yeah
that's the first one there were really a
lot of branching paths and you get the
pack a punch machine you like upgrade
the weapons they showed it briefly in
this game play today just makes the guns
insane but I remember just being
astounded how many different ways that
were to approach that cool a lot more
stuff to look forward to for zombie fans
then let us know what you think you look
forward to playing some more call of
duty let us know in the comment box
below